yo what's up it's Eric s the green ey
Bandit Happ EPMD th death squad check me
out on the boot Lake Kev podcast yeah
hey before we start the interview I'd
like to shout out our good Folks at
Imperial extraction now if you go to
Imperial extraction. right now you don't
have to buy anything nothing at all you
literally can get a free thca Diamond
loaded pre-roll so many flavors this is
the GMO cookies delivered to your door
for free okay promo code bootleg at
checkout Imperial extraction. comom get
a free I mean look at this thing this a
premium pre-roll all you have to do is
go to the website put in the promo code
and they're just going to send you one
for free what are we talking about go do
that let's get to the
interview bootle cab podcast special
guest in here a
legend Eric Surman is in the building
welcome sir what's up what's going on
man uh you know just
I was just telling my boy that it feels
strange because it's a long time to be
back on the to be back on the scene and
doing know promos and doing stuff like
that now it's podcast like you and
different type of things so it's a
little strange though but I'm cool yeah
man I mean look you've been through it
all you know what I'm saying it's crazy
cuz you somehow like not a lot of people
can say that they have the longevity to
have been through every like era of
Music in terms of like you went from
cassettes to CDs mhm to
streaming
Napster I did all of it yeah again from
1988 to 2024 it's a long time that's a
long time man and it was so many
different hats whether it's being a
record executive whether it's being
behind the scenes producing records it's
just it's it's a lot man it's a i i i
flashback on it again this it's a it's a
blessed career to be having and to still
be here and then being in front of y'all
doing you know with all the young people
and letting them know what time it is
you know few things was going on and and
and sort of In The Name Of Music you
know yeah well like let me give you my
so I as uh I'm I'm 37 I just turned 37
so when I was a kid I first got hip to
death squad right yes so that was how I
was introduced to you cuz I was a Red
Man Fan right and Method Man and red man
and and and and that's how I got hip to
like Keith Murray but I was the kind of
kid who I still have all my source
magazines all my double XS so I would go
back and like do my research on the five
mic albums and stuff like that so the
first album of EPMD that I bought I
bought it used at the warehouse and it
was I think it was your's third album it
was the one that had the record with red
man and the record with LL yes that's
third album yeah business as usual the
Rampage yeah yeah with the cops on the
front y yep yep and um and so that was
my first introdu cuz I always like knew
who EPMD EPMD right so that was kind of
like I had it's crazy that you mentioned
that because that would that ended up
getting a full mic on that record right
yep y but it's funny like just like like
my era of like hip-hop was like like
late 90s of course yeah I know early
2000s but I got to you know I got to
like kind of go back and like get the
the Brand newbi album and get all the
tribe [__] and get the EPMD [__] and
right so um but n man it's been dope to
see just kind of like your like
Evolution talk to me about like the new
project cuz it's you're doing like
collabs with everybody I know the new
singles got salt and Peppa on it right
yeah well I had the idea of doing Co
time you know what I'm saying so stopped
things but before the Hip Hop 50 I
always had ideas of just my
colleagues not being here I just figured
that you know you never know all of us
are still here yeah just because you got
young people we still have us that's
living too people want to hear music but
they stopped making music so I wanted to
facilitate that I wanted to be able to
say you know what let me make records on
people that come from the era that
people would love to hear if they was
able to make music so that's what the
Dynamic Duos came into play at so so I
want to get of course like it's like 25
rap groups yeah that are Duos right so
but I just picked it for the volume one
what I can get off now so for you it was
the inspiration was like let me do this
now CU I have this idea now cuz like you
said during Co we were losing people you
never know when people are going to be
here not going to be here who alls on
the project yeah the project is loaded
it's loaded um um I got biggy SM and
Tupac
it's going to blow everybody's away
these are are these unheard
verses it's it's not I don't to me they
are not um unheard but the way I put it
together okay it just sounds new okay
you know um Lil Wayne in
game um mob deep mop redf do you have
mob deep and mop on the same song no
okay okay these are just D Duos don't
foret two people okay two people on
okay and you handing production right
Okay cyprus
Hills dog pound apmd of
course
um this is impressive so far eight B MJG
woo I think I I I caugh everybody I
think I I mean yeah that's a lot I I
said Sno dog right no you didn't yeah
Snoop and Nate Dog mhm
Jesus so for you like I always wonder as
a producer right like if you know like
let's say the biggie and the Tupac song
do you already have that beat made or do
you get the verses and do you no I have
it I as a producer you got records you
know what I'm saying you make certain
stuff if you don't if you don't have it
then you make it I was going to say when
you hear those two verses from Biggy and
Pac does that inspire you to make the
beat off of those verses or did you
already have that no I already had some
something that I wanted I wanted to make
sure that I I didn't want to make a
regular record I don't want to make just
a hip-hop record I wanted to rock cuz
both of them is best best on Melody and
more R&B is type situations so that's
what I based my thing on when I had when
I was making it like okay I want to make
it a a song song something that biggie
would rock on something that Pac would
rock on too it feel comfortable and most
of them they records of Melody yeah you
know it's not really know the hip-hop
you know kicking you we had so many
different uh uh attempts at at at
well-known producers that we all love
and know that haven't done the best job
I would say with certain Tupac or biggie
records after they passed I I I I like I
for me I just felt that it it wasn't
something that I was trying to do
to make the biggest F I just did what
felt good to me right no that's the day
it was we want something that I feel
like it's all about like if I could hear
them like actually being on that record
when they were alive that that makes it
dope it makes it crazy
because I think that they probably would
have been friends later on yeah I think
that all that beef for the stop
eventually because of what they had
before that but but but the way I did it
you would think they was in there
together oh that's fire I was going to
say um you had like a a really early
opportunity to work with biggie right
before before we really knew who he was
is that is yeah I mean yeah I
mean my story is ill on artists because
you do have yeah you do have because you
know cuz but mindset is documented as
far as people talking yeah Rick Ross on
my basement 50 Cent in my basement
[__] ludicrous on my door the game
wuang Clan rayin says that almost sign
with Eric like you know I mean this this
thing of
M what I was able to um to see and and
and Biggy Smalls on my first video set
to where my man brought them to the
barber shop okay for me to see and then
um when I shot hitting switches My First
Single he was around the whole time why
I do every scene you know then he told
Tracy W was like yo I want to go on that
Eric serman album but I already had
artists already and then I had you know
I had my own group so I wasn't trying to
do something new but at that time I
could have you know probably would have
had that did you cuz I know biggie had
like a a buzz going around New York but
at that time did you kind of see what
eventually ended up coming to be you
know like I I didn't again my
concentration wasn't on that because I
had my own you had your own [__] you
were put yeah yeah you know I had my own
his Squad was the biggest thing running
right you know like so that's effects
Red Man Eric I mean EPMD the biggest
[__] running so it was like so at the
time it wasn't me looking at anything
else you know um talk to me about Red
Man man cuz I I I think somehow he's
turned out to be one of the more slept
on rappers ever cuz he's one of the
greatest of all time um and I think like
you know I just saw the the reaction
online from some of the young people
when Killer Mike won his Grammy which he
deserved to win 48 and he deserved to
win it cuz he had the best rap album of
the year last year y um but I feel like
these days like a guy like red man like
you know when I'm growing up like Red
Man's like the goat you know what I mean
like Muddy Waters and there's a dark
side and blackout and on and on and on
Death Squad what was it like kind of
like uh being around Red Man early like
what did you see in him that um you know
kind of had you bring him into the
fold just the the the metaphors the way
that he Rhymes you know the the word
play everything about me was as far as
um the rappers that I was able to get
like do effect and them as everybody was
Keith Murray everybody had something
different Keith Mur had the the big
words reie had you know I got AIDS [__]
you know the what lik about him you know
far
as they do effects changed the game
because you had all these groups that
either emulated them or made records
doing the igy and when you get a call
from Ice Cube saying you you know what
that fix this is Cube calling you know
what I'm saying to put them on the
record you know that these guys are
making an impact so but again but
Reggie it was just that I think that I I
saw him at a a a club in nework called
Sensations and he was with do it all
from Lords of the
Underground do it all ryed and Reggie
was his
DJ crazy right but then again he became
Lo underground later on but yeah he's
like my man rap and Reggie had one line
he said I float like a butterfly sting
like the rock group I thought it was
going to be like you know like a s like
a be yeah but he the metaphor went float
like a butterfly sting like a rock grp
so autom make I'm like yo nobody does
this right at this time
1991 or two crazy it he was already
ahead you know so I I I talk to him and
it was fast I'm like yo he regie was so
ill
that I gave him my number but not I
didn't write it down he remembered it he
remembered it that's how I used to be
back in the day though you might meet a
girl in the mall and like she'll tell
you her number but she won't write down
and it's like and and he said it it took
a couple of days for him to realize what
the number was and a few days later he
called the phone but he he had to
remember the
number that's crazy what was that
conversation like like hey I'm trying to
n just like it wasn't no me I'm just I'm
a nonot person so at the end of the day
like yo you want to do this and plus
he's a he's already a fan he don't
believe this is happening like oh [__]
I'm I'm on the phone with Eric he's
inviting me over yeah so that that was
it that's crazy man um how do you feel
about like uh because I feel like
hip-hop these days is like I always tell
people if you want to find good [__] you
gotta like it's there you just have to
it's just not being pushed like like we
just talked about the killer mic thing
but in terms of like um you know you've
been wrapped up in certain like hip-hop
uh beef situations and nowadays it's I
feel like it's it almost might be more
Amplified these days than it was back
then because back then you had to go
spend money to pick up the source and or
or the or the vibe magazine and read the
interview in which a rapper was calling
out another rapper or go buy a DVD or
whatever these days you just open your
phone and there's 30 blogs talking about
whatever conflicts going on like like
how do you feel about like the current
state of like hip-hop in terms of the
media and that kind of stuff I
mean listen to me it made it accessible
to everybody which is a cool thing right
but I just think that um the
oversaturation the music took the
excitement away from it definitely you
know as far as something coming out out
and something like waiting for Tuesday W
for yeah waiting for that though too but
to make a long story short I feel like
to
me music is making a a comeback and if
if people aren't seeing that then
they're going to be in trouble because
I'm here with you at this time of my
career yeah making music and and I'm GNA
make sure that the music is what we know
music to be like I'm not trying to to um
play the game of what everybody else is
doing everybody already doing that and
people are getting tired and it's being
proving um the
sampling that hitmaker is doing
meanwhile like taking hit Mak crazy old
records is changing the tempo back who
car if it's is Foxy Brown the tempo's
back who cares if it's um Brandy um and
Mak the temples back so that's what's
changing the game even if they are
sampling it's still changing people
don't realize the tempo like yeah it's
like like the 85 to like 100 BPM records
are like far and few between these days
it's like but it's changing so that
means that music is going to be put back
in the Forefront of what music feels
like to feel good to to inside your soul
to make you who who if they still
dancing because I went to a party
whatever they just s there with their
phones and and popping bottles people
standing at the in their sections
dancing anymore girls ain't talking to
guys guys ain't talking to girls like
what type of [__] is this this is what
we living in but I just feel that at
this time music is making a change
that's why that's why everybody's
coming we ain't going to name no artist
though but a lot of artists came out and
[__] up and they had to go back in the
studio and make rap records a lot of
people well I want to shout out uh 21
Savage just put out an album that was
heavy on substance heavy on wraps and a
lot of people wouldn't have I mean I I I
I I've kind of paid attention his
Evolution over the years but his new
album is crazy Kev what we talking about
is not farming the game is done shifted
I agree and and if people don't wake up
they're going to be in trouble they're
going to get left at the bus stop man
exactly and I'm not sitting here to be
be hating and the ho and this this and
that this is just the way it's at and we
and there's there's moves being made
that people don't know about yet that
that um that some of the the people that
we know the powers that be aren't going
to be in there yeah and they about to
move this thing forward so now
Talent it's going to with no no
algorithms no how many likes you got
none of that stuff it's all about are
you ill and are you dope that's where we
headed to that's how it used to be as
you know when I was growing up it was
like yo of course it was it was about
the bars it was about who had the crazy
you know Neil Armstrong freestyle you
know like but all the big
writers my man got a group coming out to
that's um s with ushers the girl what's
the girl name B simeons yeah the simeons
but they didn't go to the new people
they went to the Brian Michael coxes the
dreams the the you know the these people
who write music yeah like the money love
song this is where this is where we
going even Victoria mon what she did she
wrote a incredible record czy no for
sure so so this is where we at somebody
who took her 15 years he said so again
the talent is going to outweigh the
popularity this is where we at and
people can just where we going so and so
I just me being out too I give my
assessment on what I feel for young
people to know because this is important
I don't come because I'm the I'm a
person who's who's the so-called
overhead right you know I never been
broke in my life never going to be so I
don't come from a point where somebody
who's mad because I'm not in the game no
you're you been yeah you ain't never
went nowhere I'm in it to also let you
know that in for 35 years when you get
called you can go you can go perform
somebody come and watch you yeah this
new er is nobody coming to see them so
if they didn't save or have somebody do
something for them that person who turns
our age is not going to be trying to go
see [__] [__] ass [__] it won't match
no I I I say this and like I don't you
know 50 is obviously a generation after
you but uh I just went to the 50 concert
right the tour and I was just like God I
miss this like people not rapping over
their [__] tracks like you know what
I mean like that's the we that's the
crazy too and some of our veterans are
doing that I'm like where you Lear that
how you ring over the
beat did that it's crazy so so so so
this um Showmanship yeah all this comes
into play again with all the tours
that's going the new people are
struggling all the veterans sold out and
made M sold out 50 c sold out every the
Beyonce everybody that's a veteran had
no problem T yeah 100% um I I know you
and DJ Quick have worked together I
always kind of equate you first of all
quick is one of the greatest of all time
as are you but I always kind of equate
both of you guys as being like
somehow underrated producers because I
don't think people understand like quick
is like one of the greatest producers of
all time and you're not too shabby
yourself what are some of your like
bigger just production placements for
people who don't
know I I I I love David but nobody did
what I
did when it comes down to records
produce R&B and hip-hop
music my track record too big why just
mean like explain like tell us cuz I I
feel like a lot of people who are
watching this don't know your yeah
because again I've been starting off R&B
in the beginning since J since Mary
since Chico dear since D'Angelo since
SWV since invogue since Black Street
these records were done by by me these
are all R&B records from the keep sweats
all the way down this is me at R&B level
right with the biggest of the biggest at
the time and so so so now you talking
about when you talking about rap music I
did everybody and and so whatever you
want to name you want to name you can
name it like what what do you think is
like like for because there's people who
are watching this who might not know who
you are so give me like your if you had
to say top five biggest songs people
would just
know it's off the top of your head off
the top of your head you got so many
yeah just that you made that that we
don't know because you're not rapping on
them you're not you know what I mean
like people nobody's looking at the
credits anymore back in the day used to
get the booklet used to go through yeah
yeah yeah but but but but the kids the
kids won't know that because again
how how how cuz way I'm again my stuff
was mostly was mostly 90s right you know
what I'm saying so again if if I said if
I did 4321 you know about L with LJ with
with DMX and them at one time if I did
both how highs on R meth people don't
know that oh R meth is your yeah that's
my those are my boys yeah I did all of
them the blackout the blackout one too
so all them too and then again me with
um 50 Cent in the beginning my um
Heatwave was one of the first singles
before he got shot you know what I'm
saying um Reservoir Dogs with on Jay-Z
on on on the album crazy exactly you
know hey what what was it for you like
being the guy who made the be because I
always hear Ron brows talk about being
the guy who made The Ether beat what was
it like being the guy who made the 4321
beat like with everything that kind of
came with that yeah um again it was
track masters did the original record
okay and then um it was like it didn't
fit so I told Kevin Leo there was the
remix and you the remix yeah but my my
song was the remix but end up being the
the main record exactly cuz nobody never
heard that version but again I just
wanted to make my own what I thought it
should sound like and then I wanted to
put the rappers in the order that I
wanted to put the rappers in of course I
wanted to put R MEF R MEF wasn't
together on the stuff the one I heard so
of course I'm put two together back to
back and then um I I had to piece LJ's
vocals together because um it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't flowing right on the
beat so I had to chop it oh [__] yep and
um and that's why you hear me add living
on top of him so I can fill the Hol Up
I'm adding in the L for and the holes
that's crazy hey we got to stop the
interview shout out to our family at
mybookie that's right uh listen if you
go to mybookie.ag right now and you sign
up with a new account using the promo
code bootleg you're going to get up to
$11,000 first deposit bonus Now what is
my bookie first of all I've been
gambling on my bookie for at least the
last 10 years getting this money all
right and this weekend it's all about
the big game Super Bowl's going down man
Chiefs verse Niners you know I'm not
going to lie I talked myself into taking
the Chiefs plus three and I think I'm I
don't know if I want to root for Patrick
Mahomes so I might just say [__] it and
bet the Niners minus three I don't know
with that being said you don't even have
to pick either team you could pick the
color of Gatorade that's going to get
poured at the end of the game you could
pick heads or tails the coin flip at the
beginning of the game you could pick
who's going to score a touchdown so much
going on mybookie.ag sign up with your
uh promo code bootleg that's my promo
code sign up with the promo code bootleg
and uh you're going to get up to $1,000
in your first deposit bonus plus a $10
Casino chip to spend in the casino cuz
they got the full-fledged online casino
popping all right
mybookie.ag um it is going to make your
Sunday if you're going to watch the big
game a lot more interesting trust me
when I say all right also want to give a
big shout out to the good Folks at
bluechew don't forget to go over to
bluechew.com and use the promo code
bootleg right now yes right now all
right and you're going to get yourself a
free month supply of bluechew cuz
everyone's always asking me does
bluechew work yes of course but you can
find out for yourself you can get a free
month supply uh sent right to your
doorstep in discreet packaging for only
$5 shipping when you go to blu.com and
use the promo code bootleg all right
what is blue you ask
well if you have a
penis and it could always be a little
harder it maybe you're going through
some erectile
dysfunction maybe you get a little
nervous before you got to you know
perform that blue Che will have you
[__] just rocked up you know what I
mean so same active ingredients as
Viagra and seis all right no awkward
doctor visits it's all online you don't
have to go and make an appointment and
go sit in a waiting room and talk to
somebody about your [__] problems no it
all goes down right on the website
blu.com all right it's very discreet uh
and and when I say it works it works
trust me all right blue.com promo code
bootle and try it for free for a month
let's get back to the interview um what
about uh being there like like do you do
you remember like when the idea came to
be to put like meth and Red's like their
chemistry was so crazy but like to make
them a group you know what I mean well
the label they was doing that um no the
documentary first the show the show yeah
I got that I had it on VHS they wanted a
single R me so that record I did the
original one that one to the hardcore
version great movie by the way it needs
to get on nflix cuz you'll see wuang
arguing and [__] I think it's like you
got
it so how high was was something that
was made and it was like again it was I
remember being a real Smoky sex session
oh I bet you know as far as like you
know really you can't see contact people
probably think I'm just like just saying
that but it was really and I'm not a
smoker so you know that was whatever and
I don't I think that's probably where
that came from you know so
once that was going to
happen I was
like like we going to shoot a video I'm
like wait a minute you know what I'm
saying like the first those two together
we going to shoot this this record nah
because again it wasn't no it wasn't it
was a a hardcore record right just
rhyming everywhere don't forget I I had
to piece that together to make the song
work when I did
the the the radio version
mhm so long story short once they get to
the video shoot don't think they never
heard the song oh so they haven't heard
they haden't heard your final product
yet so they had the video shoot and fly
robing fly comes on and they cursing
everybody out me Dion Martel Leo Russ
what the [__] is this this yo cuz these
are hardcore people I got this [__]
[__] commercial as a [__]
singing [__] Melody the whole
nine and they end up shooting it and the
rest is history and the rest and we got
movies and TV shows out of the record
exactly right no doubt cuz I because the
Riz even say yo Eric great job you know
again because everybody was kind of not
knowing where it was going but Leo and
them liked it so they was like but you
can imagine not showing up I know they
didn't hear the record so you're going
to be mad too show put a video and you
hear and you you hear some [__] that you
never even heard heard before exactly
right and and your vocals are cut m
so where's the intro to this verse so
where's the my other eight bars to this
one so all that's gone too um talk to me
about your production process these days
because technology has uh obviously
evolved so much from when you first
started producing so what is your
production setup these days cuz what
what was your OG setup a Rolland w30 a
workstation okay like people that use
the asr1 yeah whatever I had it but I
didn't like the way it was what it was
moving for me so it worked for Timlin
for Kanye West and people like that but
to me it didn't but this station only
have 15 seconds four yeah 15 seconds
compared to a whole bunch of pble time
so it was treated like a SP 1200 the way
I had it going but I was able to play
with it so cuz me being able to play I
want to not have just a drum machine
right I wanted this too to keep so the
workstation is what I what I like what I
worked on better even though I got every
machine possible I just stayed with that
you know it was better fast forward to
2024 what's the setup and then I moved
to a um a motif okay because the motif
had mad sampling time and it had 88 keys
too that was heavy like a real piano cuz
again I got I want to play I don't want
to MIDI nothing you know I want to do
this right so and I could also program
too so I'm used to a workstation like
when I was doing Kanye West for the last
since
May soon as I came into this session
with me and him workstation
asr1 no matter what all those years in
90s one machine so if it's not broken
you know saying so again and I watch I
watch Jermaine depri on his thing when
he's sitting down too MP Rodney jerkers
everybody's back on that one machine
yeah cuz it's like nowadays like I'll
see these like younger producers and
they don't even it's just the computer
the technology can't give you that you
that analog looking for or that field
whatever like that that old machine is
so weird that everybody went back and
now the NPC just came out with the stem
thing so now they got the stem so that's
what the the best part of Technology
right now is that stem thing so now the
[__] that we dreamed about like they
talking over it you know n but you can
just take the voes out out beat out Bas
on out whatever you can sample anything
now but even if you do have the
technology do you know what to do with
it still going to be whack you can be
whack with with this machine I trying to
tell DJ I'm like you're a whack DJ it
don't matter that they got easier to be
a djack whack people that that know how
to get busy oh it's a
[__] miracle worker so you've been in
with Kanye in the last few months six
months I started in May 30th doing the
first album then after I went to Italy
Tai dollar sign was there so they had
put some thing called vultures together
yeah even though I still made that
project I've heard a lot of it yeah
even though I still made the project as
that wasn't what I was working on with
him so you were working on uh a yay
album Y3 yes okay and then you ended up
making the vultures project though no I
ended up going to Italy and the fact
that um when I got there Tai already had
sung on one of my songs already oh then
I end up doing another record too when I
when I got to Italy though too so I was
in between so hopefully when this is
done we we can get back to Y the Y3 yes
um what cuz I know like Yay has this
thing where he likes to go like certain
cities and like you know My Beautiful
Dark Twisted Fantasy was Hawaii um the
click stuff was like uh I think it was
like in Paris I mean he moves around but
what was like the Italy sessions like
what was that like it's crazy yeah
because we was in Sting's Place sting
yeah fire so his his village was
fantastic you know um and and the the
vibe in the room it's crazy how yay like
PA speakers yeah not like not like what
you would think right it's literally
like don't care about the bleeding don't
care about how loud it is he just want
to be loud doesn't matter the two Pas
and the and and and the two subs on both
of them and that's it I was in this well
I was in every room we at the hotel we
had it at the warehouse we had it in in
and where we at South Central yeah I was
in Vegas um Ty invited me out to Vegas
when the album was supposed to come out
and we ended up in y's
suite and same thing it's just two
speakers and he's tiger was in there YG
was in there uh Little Dirk was in there
all recording while just the room is
still rooming like it was never like
everybody shut up it was we was in the
addition Hotel
crazy that's crazy on the eighth floor
just that's wild and no guest nobody
said [__] did you and Tai were you guys
able to bond a bit I mean obviously you
guys yeah yeah because cuz his his
brother when I got when I first saw Tai
he stopped playing all Eric serman [__]
he's aop because he was saying that my
95 album is what his brother put them on
when I told you he played six records
and knew them all shocked the [__] out
of me you guys got to do the the green
eyes thing the green eyes Duo yeah so
but but he's one of the greatest guys in
all the world he's amazing he's a great
song writer and he's he's he's a great
guy though like a great human yeah I I I
I he was mad
nonchalant stayed smoking you know what
I'm saying but again I'm the old head
inside the place you know because again
I'm 9 years older than yay though too so
even though it's it's me and him and um
and the writers you know whatever such
and such you know give out too much but
yay is a person that whatever people say
is not what I experience he music is
music and that passion that you have as
a producer when you hear something dope
it's like yo same [__] yeah and that's
all it was about about yo being whatever
the the the you can't take nothing from
his ear the vibe the the rhyming the
context all of it that's all I saw I
don't know no other [__] I just know
what we was doing and how he felt about
me right you know he like yo ER he said
everybody in here that person who's
doing my wardrobe the person who's
building my building the one who's doing
my president campaign he said these
people over here everybody here Geniuses
that's why you here hey man you know
that's some real [__] hey take me back
to you guys taking on Rappers Delight
because another terrible uh I have to
admit that I'm I I only knew the death
squad Rappers Delight so even when I
even to this day
I know the ogers Delight but even this
day like when I like when the OG Rappers
Delight comes on I sing the the death
squad version what was that like did you
guys initially get any sort of like
blowback for like remaking such a
heralded record I listen it wasn't
something to do it was it was a project
that went on MTV yeah yeah and um they
had all the groups pick old records oh
so you guys picked that it was kind of
the theme of the project so Master P did
6:00 in the morning whatever that it's
called in the beginning okay oh I
remember the the the the there was like
the knuckles with the rings on the cover
I the problem right in the beginning so
everybody did something on there yeah so
when they came and got us this is what
we chose cuz it was three of us three y
not knowing that it was going to shoot a
video MTV number one video like we had
brought the record back like we went we
we beat Maxwell by 10,000 records to be
number one album in the country crazy
that Squad went number Uno yeah you know
because of what that was but we didn't
do it on purpose but we did get um
blowback from the original people cuz
don't think they still toring with it
yeah so now the death squad then came
and now it took away from them it took a
long time for them to be like yo cuz now
when I see like yo what's up everything
is love but at one time H wasn't [__]
with it at first right because it's
going to stop them from from from moving
around yeah you know we don't know that
I feel like the other way to look at it
is like thanks for putting some more
life into this song and but that's what
eventually happened yeah cuz like there
did you see the Grammys Tracy Chapman
performed with the this country singer
who she has a song called Fast Car from
like 1988 I know J JC yeah yeah and uh
this this country singer covered it wow
and like it was a huge country song but
they did it at the Grammys and so now
Tracy Chapman's song from 1988 no it's
number one one it's number one dope it's
crazy it's like but believe me I was
telling my man the other day like and
this this not no no Bast or nothing yeah
but um me owning my own publishing
everybody calls me so if it was for all
the 50 Cent shows you know whatever my
placements they got to call me direct I
was telling my man
that music I mean the weekend is one of
the most streaming artists in the world
right so him and Metro
boomman did I don't want to know
creeping yeah yep which is you a
customer mhm right right y only owe 4%
of that 4% of that of that
record right
4% of the
original of no of that record of Metro
boomman of of of your a customer on that
song so you own four% of creeping of of
of the publishing
right listen every four months guess how
much it brings in uh $200,000 220 wow
that's
crazy y y yo but that's 240 but that's
that's crazy how he was on the money
he's in it yeah
4% Eric talk about track and track being
wait hold on so let me get this straight
so when you because do you have to hear
the song first before you clear it yes
even when they when they did the Mad
singer and the Mad somebody on the Mad
singer sung did the record yeah mad
singer called me wow everybody has to
call because again everybody's not
fortunate because luckily Leo con and
his brother made me made me
me and Russ them made me me so I didn't
have to sell the publishing cuz people
sell publishing when they when they need
to get the money so luckily I was able
to survive without doing that for you
like uh I think most people don't
understand the how important the pub
game is because we always are pushed
like well the streaming only pays this
if you get a million streams it's like
3,800 bucks but like the real money is
really in the pub right like if you can
like own your publishing let's back this
up yeah even though streaming might be
less than one cent it's still more money
being made than you sign to a
label it's still more money being made
if you don't signed to a label is what
you're saying if you assigned to a label
and you and and and and you are
independent
streaming you is a chance that you can
make more money than being on a major
exactly yeah for sure even with the than
one penny yeah it's rough cuz you I mean
but but but but people don't know if
you're not in the game you wouldn't know
that I have a streaming company so I I
I'm witness to what it makes right on
the pub side though like CU I feel like
the publishing side of music is not
talked about enough and I also feel like
oh no people know that why you what
you've seen all the arguments with the
locks and puff and everybody with
publishing that's a always been a big
deal no I mean I'm just talking about
this new these new kids man oh they
don't have a clo they have no idea
because it's the 360 asthma they'll just
come in they'll be like how much is my
Advance yeah that's it yeah and then
they like oh [__] I don't know my
Masters or myb [__] or they'll rush into
a pub deal they they they'll get one
placement and then everybody hear what
Kev is talking about cuz Kev don't got
to do this but he is doing this he's
just trying to not to to to to to
downplay y'all but to let y'all know
what y'all have to do because this thing
is not going to is not a lasting thing
at this time this we living in moments
times of popularity things the fast food
every new every hour something is coming
yep yeah and if you catch one placement
as a producer someone's going to offer
you a c-pub deal not an admin deal and
that c-pub deal it could be I mean that
means you're full partners with a
publishing company and it could be 10
years it could be in perpetuity it could
be a lot of different things whatever
people some about the 401K or your
retirement plan this is what publishing
is it's it's your life if you're able to
have some of it please grab as much as
you can cuz you're going to get that
mailbox money every all the time it it
never stops and then all of a sudden you
might catch a placement like I just told
you yeah which is crazy how many years
later I know but but it happens but this
I'm just giving you one yeah this
happens all the time I'm just giving you
one thing about having publishing and
what it can do for you for sure man um
for you on on this uh on this new album
how cool was it to uh give the fans I
mean I know we're gonna we're when
when's the album drop
April's I think first week in April
first week of April but how cool is it
going to be to give the fans some new
EPMD after all these years yeah I mean
it's so crazy how how the label be like
yo I like the EPMD record and I'm like
are you saying because of me you know
what I'm saying but I think that I just
think that the fans are going to be
happy if I was on there burping right
because it's a it's just a cuz it's a
new EPMD song or new Cyprus Hills right
you know new so people oh yeah the M
deep [__] is crazy because because pry
right so so but again when people hear
it they like oh okay and then hopefully
I did my job for it to feel like it's
supposed to feel like cuz don't forget
our
colleagues don't go because they either
scared or like you said the records
don't come out correctly right right
right right right you know so hopefully
I was able to correct it to too like
when I was when I was here with Dre MH
as you see on my on Instagram when I was
me and Dre was in the studio and
everybody know it went
viral me and Dre made five records you
know and and he made three in one night
crazy you know off of my production
though and then I did we did another one
with
Snoop that supposed to be on the new on
the new Snoop record and and I also did
one with him that me and him rhymed on
which was crazy wow you know um but
again Kevin it's just a blessing because
I don't want to I I never talk so I hate
to be big big up myself because I'm not
used to doing that I always been
introvert always been quiet but again at
the end of the day a lot of dope [__]
that has happened in the last couple of
years for this to be what this is don't
this is only volume one so is is it
going to be a Duos thing after of course
damic Duos is my my brand I mean of
course so so so so now it's a brand of
me maker so I'm already in in like um
saying you know um you know with with
with um saying about the Larry Junes and
the and the source Walkers and all these
people that I'm looking at to do music
with you know the the the Cordes the
Freddy Gibbs all these other you work
with Freddy yet I work with Freddy back
in 2014 okay when he when he was on
inter scope or no no 2014 no no no that
was uh that was uh that was around
around the time he put out uh
bandana or Pata yeah but that was I was
there before that I've been he's been
one of my best friends since about 2010
remember the DJ that was um what's the
DJ name the one that um that he was
signed to First in 2008 2009 the ski
yeah I'm back there working with ski
yeah yeah I'm that time so I TR listen
fredd Kev one of the goats man no
rappers that wrapped didn't come to me
that's fine none if you was rapping if
you was a rapping ass [__] you
know I mean you had no no cuz only a few
of us did production right you only
going go for to a few people right
that's crazy hey we got to stop the
interview again I know you hate when I
say that it's okay hey shout out to our
family at odd Sox
though listen let me tell you something
odd Sox just celebrated their 10-year
anniversary congratulations to our
family um right now you can get 20% off
the most comfortable socks in the world
yes they got them um I tell you what
socks you can't buy at oddsocks
official.com you can't buy those blle
cev socks now you got to DM me if you DM
me for a pair of these socks I'll send
them to you in the mail for free all
right with that being said uh the most
comfortable socks in the world also they
got the draws um all the licenses look
we got Sprite here we got Doritos we got
how high we got Jaws Chucky what are we
talking about WWE the [__] power
Rangers shout out to odd Soxs oddsocks
official.com promo code bootleg save 20%
off a checkout get you a pack thank me
later also shout out to King pal yes
that's right no tobacco no nicotine the
cleanest smoke period it's what I smoke
man they got all the flavors uh and let
me tell you something what's dope about
King pom is they got these uh amazing TP
activated flavors let me show you how it
works let me grab one right here so uh
this would be the king pom energy flavor
this would be the uh the banana oh the
banana is good turpion infused tips you
squeeze and you activate the flavor you
hear that yeah all right it's all I
smoke man shout out to King Palm I love
what they got going on man I love the
flavors I love that it's organic I love
that it's it's just a nice clean Leaf
that's right it's the best Leaf to smoke
what you could do right now go to King
pom.com use the promo code bootleg and
you're going to save half off half off
50% off at checkout whatever they got
they
got wraps they got Grinders they got
ashtrays they got trays they got all
kinds of [__] what are we talking about
man go to king pom.com or you can go to
your local 7-Eleven you can go to your
local smoke shop and get loaded up with
some King pom let's get back to the
interview um tell me about
uh there was the the the the Martin
Lawrence Danny DeVito soundtrack I
forget the name of the movie yeah um
what's the worst thing Could Happen
what's the worst thing could happen but
it spared your biggest solo hit cuz I
remember being a kid and like I could
not turn on the [__] radio without
hearing music it was huge it was
everywhere I couldn't believe it I could
I to me again music wasn't not supposed
to leave my downstairs that guy my
friend Bernard he stole my CD crazy I
played it for him and he stole it out my
CD player then he went to Cali went to a
Clear
Channel um the the the record convention
and then I'm sitting on the steps of the
W A lady comes down and says yo your
song with Marvin Gay is great so now you
can imagine me Kevin I'm losing my mind
like what is she talking about and who
told her about this crazy the whole
convention had her direct record next
thing you know I go to Miami I'm number
one I'm number one and next you know it
just whatever because the headed Clear
Channel I forgot his name was at the
time he he loved it that was it it was a
smash and then Jimmy ien of course I
worked with him before
95 he was
like um for the soundtrack yeah so the
soundtrack was moving but Clive Davis
and Tommy Mata was like listen what do
what do you want so I went to Tommy Mata
said yo $2 million you know whatever
like that but no went to CLI C said tell
Eric I give him 4 Mill and I give him
half as far as 5050 me and him he make
money I make money wow that's how huge
the song was was that because was there
already a buzz for it before it like
officially was like the buzz yeah
because it happened in La okay so
everybody had already heard the record
and knew it it was already being passed
was was that was at the everybody that
was at the convention it's Clear Channel
so it was so then you have to worry
about like okay as long as y'all go get
this cleared CU then you got to clear it
but that's what happened we got stuck up
because it was a $150,000 to the estate
and then 50,000 to the lawyer so it
cost2 200 to clear the record yep for
the whole process such a great record
though man but it was worth the 200 cuz
it it it gave me it gave me it gave me a
career it gave me another half of my
life yeah cuz then after that you have
react and all of it re nobody nobody
knew that I was going to come back with
something like that afterwards because
again when something that big happens
they like oh no that's it for him and I
came right back mhm with with that yeah
for sure man um talk to me uh look at
Kev Kev you know go ahead Kev yeah I'm
hip hop man um you're part of one of the
greatest Duos of all time who's who's
the Mount Rushmore of rap Duos for you
give me the top four rap Duos of all
time Run DMC
yep um Outcast
yeah you you can't say yourself right
um that you can't let me see um wow
the the to Duos I'm stuck right now give
me the top four man Mount
Rushmore so far you're two for two
though yeah yeah yeah but but but why
why am I going
blank there's so many there's there's
there's mob deep
there's right okay you got it okay well
I'm going
go and then that's the other thing do we
consider the producer rapper as people
to the Mob deep the Gangstar the
definitely and then you
have see I don't look at the the the
down dud CU Eric be Rock Kim because
they put both names but but that's my
favorite RA in the world but again you
you have
um mop which is underrated group in the
world Billy Dan I like that's when it
comes to
underrated lyrically I mean this
fantastic [__] M was one of my
favorite rack groups of all time I saw
them perform live and they used to roll
with that chick Fox the girl who's on
for alarm Blaze and uh the sound guy
kept he was [__] with their sound at
the show and I'm like in the front row
and fox beats the [__] out of the sound
guy sound turns off sound turns off
there's no more the concert's over they
haven't even done Annie up yet these
[__] got into the crowd and did Annie
up Acappella with the crowd it was so
sick wow wow is is is Snoop and Dre a do
is no I think they got to be I mean they
are but I think they got to be like it'd
be like saying rayquan and ghost it's
like well like they were I know you're
right you're right you're right you but
I think Outcast I think EPMD when I
think Duos I think I think Gangstar I
think
uh but not but again you you you like
you said for when you think about the
the Sal pepper salt and pepper you think
about again but Run DMC of course Eric
and Parish but I'm saying is Run DMC a
Duo there's three of them right but Run
DMC is Run DMC even though they say d j
Master J to rap but I'm saying but
that's why I said do we qualify Gangstar
because Primo is just the producer right
do we qualify Eric B and rock himin
because Eric B was making beats he Rock
move that's what I'm saying so it's like
it is if we're if we're saying just the
two are like you have to also rap then
it's you guys it's Outcast it's probably
mob deep but you got to think about the
the the impact a ball theall and
MJ and UGK I would put UGK as my fourth
spot right UGK for sure humongous cuz if
you think of UGK and like how they
influenced everybody I know I got UGK on
the record
wow you got pimpy
verse come on man Kevin I think you
don't know me man like that man I don't
pimpy I know I know we always like like
there's you know the most influential
list and I think you know it's Jay it's
Pac it's you go rock him but pimpy's in
that discussion it's crazy how much pimp
oh even though it was only one album
though but I'm looking that clip still
too man Clips no no no they had three
albums they had three yeah yeah but but
but I'm saying with the the impact of
their first two albums obviously Lord
willing now you know what if you're
talking about my personal favorite
that's a different list cuz to me the
clips as you dangerous they're highly
regarded in my life danger Dangerous
yeah you right for sure man I got you so
uh first week of April the dynamic Duos
is coming y and and again at the end of
the day like it's it's a it's a
uh a situation oh too I got to help the
scar too oh hey man rest in peace to Sea
price man
again I don't know if if I'm dropping
everything at once because there's so
many and I want to be able to to to to
keep the excitement but I can go on and
tell you that nobody said no to me
people loved the idea love the concept
and everybody was like yo I got you I
got you I got you I got you you know I'm
saying so is it like um working with
because you've already oh Styles P and
Jay oh I mean shout out to them but I
was going to say the fact they've never
did that album together just the two you
know they need to do just the the they
need to do their version of Iron Man or
you know only buil for Cuban links right
um well well they did
to the two purple tapes no I'm talking
about ghost F or I'm talking about Jada
and styles oh J
I want them to just do their version of
that yeah but I don't know but they
don't want to leave out she I get um
with that being said though uh is it is
it like because you you have a lot of
people on that on this project or on
these projects that aren't with us
anymore yes uh Prodigy uh Sea price
Tupac but I was going to ask you like is
it is how is it like how much is it like
when you hear Sean Price vocals for the
first time like I feel like I would get
goosebumps and just be like damn
like the is the pressure higher knowing
you got to have to kind of like deliver
because n because again it doesn't you
know it's like you you dope at what you
do yeah I ain't whack right no for sure
so so when when that beat come on it's
going to be like
oh why not back right you know cuz I'm I
don't have a it sounds de posy that come
from his brother Leo Cohen you know
if sound de posy mean somebody say yo
how you like that oh that's dope yeah I
don't have the people that's agreeing
you know don't don't agree with me you
don't [__] with it don't [__] with it
just tell me the truth right right right
you know what I'm saying so that's what
I I like about people who I'm around you
know and I know if it's not good cuz I
sit there and sit there myself and be
like oh nah this I could have had some
better drums you know what I'm saying
what uh what did you like cuz coming up
like' 80s Death Jam is kind of like
hip-hop [__] allore like when we
think about what that F Jam meant it was
we think about the ' 80s right I think
your guys's logo you know what I mean
'90s yeah so for me it's like uh I want
to know what is something that you were
able to learn from being around leor and
Russ yeah that's and also the fact that
you were able to kind of like just
Thrive under them in like a way that I
don't think a lot of people would expect
like yeah cuz I was a I was one of the
producers and um along with the group
you know what I'm saying like Leo tell
the story
sometimes when when when when Def Jam
was was in trouble red man came to to
bail out yeah that was like uh that that
weird era where it was like jail felony
the the r thing that that was moving in
transition between polygram and whatever
they always say Warren G's regulate help
save the label for a I mean Leo don't
hold no punches about what he speaks
about how things were need money to hold
thing up too but again EPMD was the
fifth group sign a Death Jam so at the
early time when we was when Russell came
and got us from SE bag records because
they had to audit and when we came that
was the first time that we saw that
um what that we was in that it it things
could be better right because we had
number one albums in the country back to
back and we didn't have any money cuz at
first you don't look at the money in the
beginning but then when you when time
goes by and and and we are fire like
that it it didn't match yeah and Russell
was like we got to get them off of there
and and they got us off of there and
they we signed for $1.6 million at Death
Jam at that time in 91 crazy what was
your um first Nationwide tour like Run
DMC open up for it was a 88 it was EPMD
Public Enemy J Jeff FR Prince Jesus you
know and and the runs house tour was the
tour and and Russell was run told
Russell go get them boards from Long
Island you know because don't forget
we're the up and cumings this is Run DMC
so they so at this time the projectory
of of trying to make the tour U run make
sure we got the hottest people on it cuz
Jack Jeff and F is on fire so public
enem is on fire and then all of a sudden
these two guys from Long Island EPMD is
on fire to the point where when when um
we on the on and and Fresh Prince has
stopped the show and said hold up want
to congratulate EPMD for number one
album in the country me and PR know what
what that means right on on Billboard
what do you mean with
number but EPMD was that Phenom we was
number one in the country back to back
boths what was it like backstage though
like at the hotels during those days
because that's it crazy because it was
Arenas so so again to be in arenas and
have like the the calone cases full of
clothes or Adidas or like basketball
rims in the back like the stuff that you
hear about is what it was but we I'm a
kid so all this stuff is still brand
spanking new and don't forget me and
Paris rode on run dmc's bus we didn't
have the money for a bus and run invited
us to ride with them wow so now
automatically you guys you guys got your
own bunk on their bus I'm on the bottom
though yeah but I'm watching the Adidas
walk by every morning to get off the bus
you know but it was something special
because they didn't have to do that but
they did that's so crazy to think that
that to happened public anemy Run DMC
PMD and fresh prince and Jazzy Jeff wow
that's crazy runs house and I don't know
where the footage is I always ask
Charlie Mack he says oh no I have it I'm
like this the only thing on on YouTube
that we can't see yeah there's footage
for everything else it feels like
there's but that one of the biggest
tours like after you know freshfest and
all that stuff somebody's got to have
VHS or something somewhere in a closet
they haven't came out yet yeah that's
got to be yeah that's crazy man well
look I appreciate you pulling up me too
it's a great interview appreciate that
thank you man the new albums coming
first week of April fully produced by
it's going to be crazy because you gonna
be like yo Eric was here talking about
this [__] now I heard this [__] you know
can't wait to hear hopefully Monty let
you how many um how many volumes you
think you're going to doing well I'mma
do another dynamic duo yeah with with
with the young people okay with all
young rappers though right the the ones
that know had a ride right so um and
then I'mma do a soloist okay um still
under the name d Duo then I'mma do R&B
thing where all the R&B acts that that
people not talking about I'm putting
them together too that's going to be
hard there it is man don't forget it's
an easy process this is like you do this
in your sleep much is it might sound
like a lot it's nothing well I
appreciate you pulling up I look forward
to hearing it man Eric shman boom Kev
there you go fire want to shout out to
harden man hey don't forget this
interview was brought to you by Harden
and when you're hitting Las Vegas you
got to stop off at harden tell the Uber
driver the Taxi Driver take me to harden
they going to take you they going to get
you right you know what I'm saying make
sure you go visit them at Hardin
vegas.com go follow him Hardin Las Vegas
and when you go and check out the most
craziest Premium Selection of cannabis
in the world um make sure I you tell
them I sent you they're going to get you
situated salute to harden thank you for
watching